>> Laura: MORE OF MY EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW EARLIER THIS EVENING
WE LEARN NOT TO TRUST POLLS ALL
THAT MUCH ON THE 2016 ELECTION,
BUT MUCH OF THE MEDIA JUST
CANNOT STOP OBSESSING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S RELATIVELY LOW
POPULAR TOME OF POPULARITY.
I ASKED THE PRESIDENT IF THE TAX
REFORM TRIUMPHS WILL LIFT THE
PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATING.
>> Laura: WHY DO YOU THINK HIS
NUMBERS ARE WHERE THEY ARE?
PRESIDENT AT THIS POINT IN HIS
FIRST TERM.
I'M NOT ALL ABOUT THE POLLS,
BELIEVE ME, BUT ALL THINGS
CONSIDERED IT'S BETTER TO BE
POPULAR THAN NOT.
IT GOING INTO THIS NEW YEAR,
MIDTERM ELECTIONS, THE GENERIC
BALLOT, EVERY POLL SHOWS
REPUBLICANS DOWN DOUBLE DIGITS.
WHAT DOES THE TRUMP-PENN'S TEAM
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANICS.
WHERE PEOPLE DON'T LIKE YOU VERY
MUCH AND SO THAT STORY?
>> LET ME SAY AT ONE OF THE
ENDURING LESSONS FOR ME OF THE
ELECTION 2016 WAS DON'T BELIEVE
THE POLLS.
I DON'T REMEMBER A POLL THAT HAD
US ANYWHERE CLOSE TO WINNING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WON A HISTORIC
>> Laura: YOU >> Laura: YOU
SAW THE TURNOUT IN THE ALABAMA
RACE.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS CAME OUT,
WOMEN CAME OUT.
TO GET DELIVERING.
THEY WILL KEEP TALKING, THEY
WILL KEEP RESISTING, WE WILL
KEEP DELIVERING.
AND AS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE
US WITH A STRONGER AMERICA AT
HOME AND ABROAD, A SAFER
AMERICA.
THINK ABOUT THE PROGRESS ON THE
INTERNATIONAL STAGE.
OUR HOURS ARE CONTRIBUTING AS
NEVER BEFORE.
NOT CERTIFIED THE IRAN NUCLEAR
DEAL.
AND THE ISIS CALIPHATE HAS
COLLAPSED.
WE'VE ACTUALLY TAKEN BACK WITH
>> Laura: THAT'S WHY ASKED THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE POLLS.
THAT IS AN UNBELIEVABLE RECORD
IN ONE YEAR.
BY ANY STANDARD IF PEOPLE ARE
BEING OBJECTIVE.
BUT THE MEDIA, THE ESTABLISHMENT
MEDIA DOESN'T WANT TO GIVE A
SHRED OF CREDIT TO THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
MANY OF THEM ARE ACTUALLY
CREDITING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE ECONOMY,
BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
I KNOW YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN THE
POLLS, BUT YOU DON'T THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT IN THE MIDTERMS
WITH THESE CRITICAL SENATE RACES
GIVEN YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO WANT PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
RESIGN.
A BUILDING MOVEMENT TO
IN THE SENATE AND HOUSE DON'T
YOU NEED THAT MAJORITY?
>> LET ME BE CLEAR.
I'M SKEPTICAL ABOUT WHAT THE
POLL NUMBERS ARE.
BUT I THINK YOU CAN COUNT ON THE
FACT THIS PRESIDENT, MYSELF, OUR
ENTIRE TEAM, WE WILL BE
CANVASSING ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
THE NEXT YEAR.
I REALLY HAVE TO TELL YOU.
WE LIVE IN A VERY DIVIDED TIME
IN THE LIFE OF THIS NATION.
AND I THINK THE PRESIDENT AND I
TRULY BELIEVE THAT BEING IN THE
EVERY YEAR ON AVERAGE FOR THE
LAST EIGHT YEARS HAS CREATED A
LEVEL OF FRUSTRATION.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT COINED THAT
PHRASE, THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND
WOMEN OF AMERICA, HE TAPPED INTO
A FRUSTRATION IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT THEY WERE FEELING
AND THEY KNEW IT COULD BE
BETTER.
IF THEY KNEW THE ECONOMY COULD
BE STRONGER.
THEY KNEW WE COULD BE STANDING
AGAIN AND COMMANDING THE RESPECT
OF NATIONS AROUND THE WORLD.
WHICH IS NEEDED NEW LEADERSHIP
TO DO IT.
AND I TRULY DO BELIEVE THAT AS
WE GO FORWARD AND WE TELL THAT
STORY AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SEE THOSE RESULTS, I THINK WE
WILL SEE SOME OF THIS DIVISION
IN THE COUNTRY BEGAN TO WILT
AWAY AS WE SEE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES, WAGES BEGIN TO
RISE.
OUR MILITARY STANDING TALL AND
STANDING STRONG AGAIN.
>> Laura: HAVE YOU BEEN
INTERVIEWED BY THE MUELLER TEAM?
>> I HAVE NOT.
IT HAS BEEN DEMONSTRATED THAT
KEY MEMBERS OF THIS
INVESTIGATION ARE LOYALIST OF
EITHER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
AND/OR HILLARY CLINTON.
KNOWING WHAT YOU KNOW AND
PROBABLY WHAT YOU'VE SEEN ABOUT
SOME OF THESE INVESTIGATORS WHO
>> LET ME SAY WE ARE FULLY
COOPERATING WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO.
OF THIS PRESIDENT.
I THINK THE REASON YOU SAW US
PASS THE LARGEST TAX CUT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY, I THINK THE
REASON YOU'VE SEEN THE PROGRESS
OF A STRONGER AND MORE
PROSPEROUS AMERICA AT HOME AND
ABROAD IS BECAUSE WHATEVER
WASHINGTON, D.C., HAS BEEN
FOCUSED ON, THIS PRESIDENT,
MYSELF, OUR ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE BEEN FOCUSED
ON WHERE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
FOCUSED.
WE WILL LET THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
DO THEIR JOB AND CONTINUE TO
COOPERATE.
>> Laura: 'S THEY TOOK ALL
THOSE TRANSITION EMAILS.
>> WE WILL CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
OUR JOB.
I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT US TO DO.
>> Laura: IT DOES TAKE UP TIME
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO DOCUMENT
PRODUCTION.
YOU HAVE TO CONSULT WITH
COUNSEL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE HAVE TO HIRE
LAWYERS.
I REMEMBER WORKING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AS A YOUNG 20
SOMETHING IN THIS BUILDING AND I
DIDN'T HAVE TO HIRE A LAWYER,
THANK GOD.
THAT MUST NOT BE VERY FUN AND A
LOT OF REPUBLICANS THINK THIS
INVESTIGATION IS PROCEEDING IN
AN UNFAIR MANNER BECAUSE OF THE
TYPES OF INVESTIGATORS THAT ARE
ON STAFF.
AND IT CONTINUES TO BE A PROBLEM
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> I CAN JUST TELL YOU AND YOUR
VIEWERS THAT WE'RE JUST GOING TO
CONTINUE TO COOPERATE.
THEY SHOULD KNOW WE WILL
CONTINUE TO STAY RIGHT FOCUSED
WHERE THEY WANT.
WHEN I'M TRAVELING AROUND THE
COUNTRY I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU,
AGAIN PRESENT COMPANY EXCEPTED.
WHEN YOU ARE TRAVELING ON THE
COUNTRY, PEOPLE ARE STICKING
THEIR HAND OUT, SHAKING HER HAND
SAYING THANKS FOR WHAT YOU ARE
DOING FOR THE MILITARY.
IF TELL THE PRESIDENT THANKS FOR
WHAT HE'S DOING STANDING WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
TELL HIM THANKS FOR WHAT WE ARE
SEEING IN THIS ECONOMY ONCE
AGAIN.
PEOPLE ARE STANDING TALL AGAIN
AND ON A DAY LIKE TODAY WHEN WE
SEE THE CONGRESS UNDER
HISTORY, THE BIGGEST TAX
REFORM --
>> Laura: SO MUCH FOR THE
DIVIDED REPUBLICAN PARTY.